when should we bring out the cake 1 or 1
30. one's good
1 30. phyllis i need you to pick up
green streamers at lunch
i thought you said green was [ __ ] no
orange is [ __ ]
okay we only have three hours people to
plan a whole luau
you're not helping what are the
ingredients of poi
i called every grocery store in scranton
and no one sells whole pigs
did you try the petting zoo
isn't 7 p.m a little late for a lunch
party
lunch party it's supposed to say launch
party
what is wrong with you angela is worse
than usual lately
and we have a party to throw so i
googled
how to deal with difficult people and i
got
all of this so we're gonna try out some
new things today
so how do you feel about the fact that
the banner says lunch
i feel angry angry at you angry at you
for doing something
stupid angry at me for believing you
could do something not stupid
i'm so sorry to hear that that must be
awful it is awful
you've made this day awful maybe you
could just change the u
into an a then it would say lance party
kevin
would it really be better if it said
lance party oh lunch party
it's supposed to say launch okay wow
easy booster seat nobody cares about
this party anyway
i care plan a party angela oh and the
entire world will see it oh and here's
65
for your budget oh and here are four
idiots he'll do nothing but weigh you
down
oh and your cat's still dead
i asked for assorted cutlery and i got
back spoons
these are worthless i want to understand
what you're saying but it's difficult
for me when you use that tone
phyllis these are spoons
spoons have rounded tops and are used to
scoop
things what we need are forks
which have prongs or tiny spears on top
and we need knives which have blades
do you understand me now yes
goody
you can pick one of these things it's
unreasonable for you to ask me to do all
of this
it should take you no time at all if you
put the care into it that you normally
do
ow that seemed to shut her up
i want a party that makes me feel like i
am flying through the air
without this ugly weight
holding me down you know
i want an anti-gravity machine i saw it
in a movie
you drink a potion and then you start
floating all around
so how much anti-gravity potion do you
want no no you know what this is not a
party planning committee anymore
and i don't want your foot money and i
feel uncomfortable participating
phyllis can you do this
yes
hi are there any local companies that
rent anti-gravity
machines anti-gravity machines that's
right yeah
what do they do exactly they make you
feel lighter
anti-gravity um
anti-depressant i could put you through
to someone on that
okay hello angela phyllis
you look like you're gonna have a heart
attack can i get a list of your vendors
i shredded it why would you do that gosh
i just don't know
why do you think
sorry
all right we're here for daryl and his
band
you know what let's also give a shout
out to phyllis for this awesome
party huh probably the best one that we
have ever had
[Applause]
but the real reason
well i hope you had fun today because
you're never ever throwing a party again
[Music]
party planning's a real high like a
runner's high
angela you'll go to the supermarket and
get the new york cheesecake
make sure it's the generic one it's
stanley's favorite
yes uh i've replaced angela as head of
the party planning committee
i guess i was just in the right place at
the right time
is this it i mean is this two bowls of m
m's and some balloons you know what
phyllis i think you need to step it up
i think you need to get the let out
because if i'm not mistaken
we gave you your wedding shower here we
all came into this room and gave you
a golden shower well you know what
where's my golden shower
phyllis i do enjoy being the head of the
party planning committee i'm no longer
under angela's heel
and her little grape head is under mine
what are you doing
don't talk to them i'm sorry make the
party don't
make the party please phyllis
pump it hey phyllis
do i need this invite to get into the
party yes awesome
i think this is going to be the best
christmas party
ever angela
you're gonna move this for the party
right it's not on theme
it's the nativity scene
all right you could keep your camel
sheep elephant and the north african
king can stay everything else
goes in the drawer i am not going to
judge phyllis for desecrating christmas
there is one person who will though and
phyllis just stuffed him into a drawer
i need you to get rid of the tree but
thank you
oh i don't think it's blackmail angela
just does what i ask her to do so i
won't tell everyone that she's cheating
on andy with dwight
i think for it to be blackmail it would
have to be a formal letter
it looks like i'm going to be here for a
while so why don't you make a little
plate of hummus for everyone
little triangles of pita toasted on both
sides fans so you can easily grab them
and napkins fanned
[Music]
please stop making me do these things oh
sorry it's your job
but it's the season of mercy you never
showed me mercy when you were in charge
why aren't you wearing the hair net i
lost it
okay nice
that's a hawa shibaki a cookie they
serve it during ramadan
[Music]
i need you to put the christmas tree
back up it's outside
i didn't ask you where it was i told you
where it needs to be
shut up excuse me
i'm not moving the tree face it the only
power you have over me
is this little secret that i know you're
not gonna tell
oh and you wanna know how i know that
because then you won't be able to play
on your stupid tacky parties anymore
so you move the tree
okay
angela's having sex with dwight
i caught them doing it after toby's
going away party
well don't look so surprised
all right everybody's still here perfect
got a little surprise i've been working
on
angela my bride i just wanted you to
know that for the rest of our lives
no matter the cultural milieu
i will always be there to bring you some
christmas cheer deck the halls with
bowser
t is the season to be jolly
la la la la la la dawn we now are gay
apparel follow
[Music]
do
i think i'd like to go home now sure
a tough room come on i just learned it
just so you know protocol is a little
round of applause but
merry christmas to all and to all a good
night
you